- Hey man, thank you.
Do you care if I eat these noodles?
- Yeah, no, that's fine.
(soft bumbling music)
(spraying)
Fuck!
(soft bumbling music)
- [Woman] So how's the social life?
You making any friends?
- If I'm gonna transfer, making friends
seems like kind of a waste
of time, don't you think?
- [Woman] No.
- Well I'll try, I'm trying.
I don't wanna be here
very much longer, mom.
I can enjoy myself when I get to Harvard.
- Well you can already
get into schools like UCLA
with a 1350.
- Yeah, but the, um,
the Ivy leagues take 1450s and above.
- Right, but,
it's just that taking
the test like seven times
feels pretty obsessive.
Most of our students only take it around
three to four times.
- Yeah, okay.
Um,
I think I can do better than a 1350.
Do you think that?
- No, yeah, of course you can.
- [Woman] Are you doing anything for fun?
- [Josh] Playing basketball.
- [Woman] Are you doing okay?
- I'm fine.
- [Woman] You're not to stressed out?
- No, I'm not too stressed out.
(crashing)
- [Woman] Good luck on your test.
I love you.
(soft bumbling music)
(upbeat electronic music)
- What's tomorrow?
- Oh, I'm taking the SATs.
- Oh.
Yeah, you want some Adderall?
- No, I'm good, thanks.
I'm actually trying to clonk out early.
- Okay, big mistake.
- I know it's Halloween, but,
would you mind keeping
it down when you come in
later tonight?
- Oh yeah, I'm getting
up hyper early tomorrow
to get in line to get some Enya tickets
so I'm conking out early.
- Oh well that solves,
like, all of my problems.
- [Harvey] Ooo, congrats.
- [Josh] I guess I'll go bed--
- Okay, take care, dude.
Good luck.
- Thank you.
Enjoy Enya and, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Harvey, um, while I'm here.
Your checks.
- Uh, yeah, I don't have a pen.
- Oh, I got a pen.
- I don't have my checks.
They're coming in the mail, but,
you know how long it takes.
Government system.
Express.
- Ah, great, okay.
Well, I guess I'll
check you later.
- [Harvey] Check you later.
(laughing)
Nice dude, nice.
Write that down.
(slow, soft music)
(upbeat pop music)
♫ Play the song
♫ Girl you know you'll
always be my number one
♫ Ooo, ooo, ooo
- Fuck.
(upbeat pop music)
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Woman On Podcast] Bring your
awareness to your breathing.
(hitting)
(upbeat hip hop music)
342 Alvarado Street.
- [Operator] Sir, is this an emergency?
- Um.
(knocking)
- Hey.
- Young Woody Allen,
that's good, I like that.
- Thanks.
Um, would you mind turning the music down
just a little?
- It's a Halloween party, dude.
Like--
- No, I know, I'm sorry to bother you.
- It's like 11.
- I have a really big
test tomorrow and I was--
- No, I'm sorry.
It's not my party.
If you wanna come in and talk to somebody,
you're welcome to, but
I'm not gonna go in there
and turn it down.
- Do you know the homeowners?
Do you know anybody running the party?
- [Woman] They're somewhere.
- Okay, um.
- How about you come in and find them?
- No, I just.
Tell 'em I stopped by.
- Okay.
What's your name?
- [Josh] Josh.
- Okay.
Happy Halloween, Josh.
- If you get this message, just, like,
uh, keep the music down.
And have a wonderful
Halloween.
Okay, thank you, bye.
(upbeat jazzy music)
(upbeat hip hop music)
(upbeat punk rock music)
(upbeat jazzy music)
(music cuts off)
(people chattering)
(upbeat electronic music)
I'm sorry.
Ma'am, can I--
Sorry.
(knocking)
Hi, um, I live next door.
- [Woman] Can you please give me a minute?
- Sorry to bother you.
Um, we can hear your music.
- [Woman] Not right now, okay?
- Okay, but could you
like turn your music down
just like a little bit?
- [Woman] Just get out of my house.
- Because I have like a big test tomorrow.
- [Woman] Get out!
- Okay.
(upbeat reggaeton music)
- Hey!
Man, you came out!
Yeah, isn't this party amazing?
Hey, don't you have a test?
(upbeat reggaeton music)
(hitting)
(music distorting)
Oh my god, isn't this party amazing?
Hey, I thought you had a test.
(upbeat reggaeton music)
Alright.
See you later.
(tense electronic music)
(mumbling)
(ripping)
(crashing)
(tense electronic music)
(hitting)
(yelling)
(heavy breathing)
- [Woman] Students with
temporary medical conditions
must apply for postponement
a minimum of three days
in advance of their test day.
- Please, my test is in two hours.
- [Woman] I'm sorry.
Would you like to
reschedule to next February?
- No, my applications are due in January.
I need,
I need my scores in.
- [Woman] I'm sorry.
There's really nothing I can do.
(slow, soft music)
(Harvey laughing)
- Oh man, that party
was a riot last night.
I slept through Enya--
- You're two months late on your rent.
I need you to pay.
- Yeah, I'll get it to you next week.
- I need you to pay now.
- Dude, I'm in the middle of a program.
(laughing)
(hitting)
(crashing)
Dude, what the fuck?
(deeply inhaling)
This is gonna hurt also.
So why are you being like this?
- 'Cause I'm a fuck up.
- Dude--
- I've taken the SATs
seven times now, right?
- Okay.
- Yeah.
Do you know what it takes to
get into an Ivy League school?
At least a 1500.
Yeah, I mean, I know I should be grateful
for the opportunity--
- Oh my god, you're gonna
get into a fantastic school.
You're like a brain.
You know.
- Thank you.
But you don't get it.
- Oh, poor baby, he's not gonna maybe
get into Stanford.
If you're a fuck up,
what does that make me?
- I didn't mean it like that.
- Yeah, I know.
But,
look.
Do you know Kanye West?
Kanye West is a fantastic producer.
He's an okay rapper, I don't
understand all of his lyrics.
But,
that dude works so hard.
He's just like always in the studio,
rippin' out fat beats.
But that dude does not give a fuck,
so maybe you should try
changing your perspective.
Work hard, yeah, but care less.
Boo yah.
Look, I'm gonna go to my buddy's house.
I'm gonna get 600 bucks.
I'm deducting 200 for that TV.
It was Hi-Def.
So, you know, but I'll have the rest
in a couple of weeks.
In the mean time, if you
want to, you can smash
a couple more of my things.
You know, I get to choose
them, though, this time.
- Yeah, I can do that.
I am
so sorry.
- Don't even worry.
I should read more anyways.
Are you gonna be okay?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
♫ Carefree
♫ So carefree
♫ Feeling strong
♫ I'm carefree
♫ So carefree
♫ I wonder why it took so long
♫ But it's looking up now
♫ My hope's been found
♫ And I ain't got the time to feel down
♫ Things are looking up now
♫ My hope's been found
♫ And I ain't got the time to feel down
♫ You know we're gonna make it,
you know we're gonna make it